uh i think
we should go ahead and get started you
know people are still trickling in but
yeah
uh do you want to
start sharing your slides
all right i guess i'll go ahead and
start us off here yeah so thanks for
coming back to the uh afternoon session
uh you know today we're really happy to
have ann noe here virtually to uh start
us off
with uh learning automata for
multi-agent rl so and i'll let you take
it away
thank you
so um good afternoon for you
here it's already quite late in the
evening
so i'm happy to be virtually uh
participating here in this workshop of
course i would have liked to be there in
person
but unfortunately i couldn't make it so
indeed i'm going to talk
today about learning automata and and
how i think they can be used for
multi-agent uh reinforcement learning
uh so i think today
yeah i
seem to have a problem ah okay i could
not advance my slides but it seems to be
fixed
um
so i think it's safe today to say today
that uh basically the state of the art
of deep uh multi-agent reinforcement
learning and centralized
learning and decentralized
execution
so
we don't seem to really manage to
have
really independent uh learning agents um
while as i will show you uh in a few
more slides um that we could actually do
this in the past but before i show this
i'm going to show you here a movie of uh
long which is in recently developed
algorithm by raphael who's actually with
you there in the room
who
made such a deep rl algorithm and the
key
elements of the algorithm or
that it actually moves away from the
volume factorization and instead
uses a centralized value combined with
local advantages and to stabilize the
individual learning agents and a nice
property of the
algorithm is also that it has nice
scalability
properties and
i don't know if you actually
paid attention to the movie because i
was still talking uh so the the strategy
uh that you see is that uh some uh agent
one agent is actually attracting the
enemies and giving the other agents the
opportunity uh to defeat this this other
enemies and to actually uh go to the
goal so this is uh
normally a very hard map called corridor
and where other algorithms have uh real
problems in in dealing with uh the
challenges uh here
uh but today i'm going to talk about and
this this learning automata and i will
try to explain you uh why and and first
i'm going to take you a bit back in
history
uh and i'm going to um
show how we actually looked at
multi-agent reinforcement learning uh in
the past and then we typically made the
uh difference between what we were
calling sparse interactions so like you
see in this uh grit world here so we
have these agents that are uh moving uh
mainly uh independent from each other
and it's only in particular states and
that they
have to coordinate so the basic id of
the algorithms that were
developed like 10 or even 20 years ago
were
trying to figure out uh in which states
agents had to
coordinate so
if an agent was in a certain state it
was
trying to automatically find out
um
in how it had to coordinate with other
agents when they were in specific states
so part of the problem was also and to
deal with observation and so what was
the range of uh the observation the
agents uh needed to have to have in
order to deal with this uh problem so
the main part was like independent
agents independent learning agents
within some coordination mechanism
that was triggered in
specific states
at the other side of the spectrum we
have agents that are
let's say constantly interacting with
each other um so here we have an example
again of a quite old algorithm
where the idea is that and the agents
which are here colored either blue or
red have to coordinate uh have to agree
i could also say on a certain color and
they can only do so by interacting with
their neighbors and so they're
positioned here in the ring structure so
they ain't only interact with their
neighbors and if they have the same
color and it's a positive reward if they
have a different color they have a
negative reward
and they just apply a simple learning
algorithm
in order to converge to agree uh on a
certain color
and the nice thing about the algorithm
was that um
that even if there was um let's say they
reached a solution and if there was an
uh
a disturbance and they could converge
back uh to a solution uh which was not
the case of all the algorithms uh back
then
and you can also use such a
approach and not to just agree uh on a
color which we call at the left hand
side you can
a convention that emerges but it also
could also be to like anti-coordinate
like in a dispersion game or to have a
kind of uh mix between coordination and
anti-coordination like what you would
need in a setting of traffic lights
uh today unders people typically talk
about under moving target problem which
basically um refers to the fact that um
if you are one agent and from your
perspective and the other agents are
also learning and that it um
generates um
disturbances so to say so uh there is an
issue if you want to learn and the other
agents are also acting
at the same time
uh but i think there's an additional
issue uh which is not always expressed
explicitly and and these are the fact
that the rewards themselves can also be
stochastic
and
also again an old
id
or actually commitment sequences and and
since i think it really pinpoints the
the challenges we have in
multi-agent reinforcement learning i i
wanted to mention this so the idea of
commitment sequences is that sequences
are generated according to a certain
protocol so all the agents involved in
uh the game and they know about the
protocol they know about how to generate
a sequence
and
whenever a
a time step belongs to a certain
sequence so for example time step one
belongs to the first sequence time step
two to the second one and time step
three belongs again to the first
sequence so whenever
a time step belongs to a certain
sequence
that already started and the agent is
committed to play the action it was
playing
in the beginning of the sequence so all
the agents know about this
so whenever
uh an agent then
um
plays an action and it receives a reward
that is different from a reward that it
has experienced
earlier
in that same sequence it basically knows
that and this
difference comes from the fact that the
rewards are stochastic and not because
the other agent is exploring them
because the other agent is committed to
say to play the same action as it was uh
playing previously within that sequence
of course
um you you can see that the time steps
become bigger and bigger within a
sequence and so there's always room for
new new sequences uh to start
and this allows the agents to uh use a
normal exploration strategy and to focus
on uh
more promising uh actions
so i think this is a nice principle and
because it pinpoints the difference
between
uncertainty because the other agents are
acting and
the fact that the rewards themselves can
be stochastic
of course a downside or an
important assumption that is being made
here is
yeah there is of course a common
protocol for defining these commitment
sequences
but there is also a global clock
because
um you need to have these time steps so
and the different agents have to stay in
sync otherwise and
this will of course uh fail
but i like the the principle of
differentiating between uh these two
aspects
um so now i'm going to talk a bit about
uh learning automata and they are like
um policy iteration
uh approaches so on the slide you can
see
a um an
updating rule for um learning automata
so uh decay refers to the time step
so that's the normal
notation for learning about tomata to
use k and not t so i stick to the
normal
way of writing the update scheme
and i and j
refer to the
actions of the agent so here we are in a
scenario where we have discrete
actions
so the first rule is how the probability
of the action that is being taken
is updated and while the rule for j
applies to all the actions that were not
selected and they are also updated
and you can verify that if you start
with a probability vector
so uh if you take the probabilities over
all the eight over all the actions and
they sum up to one before you do an
update and they will still sum up to one
after doing uh this update so a learning
automata really has a built-in
exploration strategy because you update
these probabilities um directly
now you might of course wonder yeah
and i i stress the fact that it is has
that it has this building uh exploration
strategy and you can wonder why uh i
stress this well
if you have a learning automaton with
only two actions you can perfectly mimic
the exploration strategy if you would
just have a kind of q learner and you
would learn q values you can mimic this
exploration strategy
uh with the
normal um exploration strategy but
if you have um more than uh two actions
so three or more
then you cannot just mimic this
exploration strategy yeah that would
lead if you would learn q values and
then you would like to mimic this
exploration strategy and that would lead
to a very sophisticated exploration
strategy which would be very atypical um
because it would uh in a very strange
way uh condition its its uh selection
probabilities on on the combination of q
values so that would be something very
strange uh to do
so
this building explorations filter g is
really uh interesting as we will see uh
later on and then different variants of
these uh reward schemes and so for
example also a is the
learning rate so to say based on a
positive reward so how much you want to
reward on the b refers to like
penalizing uh the uh action
uh so that's another learning rate
and the ones
that we are going to talk about here or
the ones that we call reward in action
so that's basically where we put uh the
b
uh equal to zero
and now i'm going to show you some
typical uh learning curves
uh so uh here we have a scenario with
only two actions
and uh we have the rewired probabilities
for the action so action one here
is the better action because it has a
higher probability on a positive reward
and the different plots you see is for
the different um
learning rates yeah of course the
smaller the learning rates the smoother
the learning curve but what is here
mainly interesting is this gamma so uh
which is the ratio between a and b and
so the reward in action one is the one
on top
so where a is equal to 0.1 and b is
equal to uh zero
um and as you can see it uh basically
learns a pure strategy so it gives the
probability mass 1
to the
better action
and if you put these learning automata
in a game setting
then we'll see that uh they converge to
a uh nash equilibria or a national
equilibria is actually an attractor for
this
independent learner so this is really
important and that our agents or just
um
updating their own uh
probabilities based on their own
observations so the only information
they get is their own reward they cannot
observe anything about the other agents
so it's going to be well known for the
audience here and that we have to pure
nash equilibrium
equilibria and we have one mixed one and
so what uh you see at the right hand
side it's actually under dynamics of
this learning automata
so the
two nash equilibria will be unlike
attractors so
um
so
the different lines uh plots you see
there at the right hand side or actually
a trace
of how these probabilities are being
updated and as you can see and the nash
equilibrium to the left
bottom is an attractor and the one to
the right top is an attractor
and uh mixed nash equilibrium which is
here an unstable uh mixed nash
equilibria equilibrium is actually an
unstable point for the learning so they
will typically be attracted to this pure
nash equilibria
and this is actually um
something that has been proven by
narendra and wheeler
so if we apply this reward in action
update schemes for independent learners
in an in-person
non-zero sum game and they will always
converge to a pure nash equilibrium
point
of course not all games have an pure
nash equilibrium and so if there is a
pure nash equilibrium and then will be
one of the attractors
of
these learning automata
yeah
so
they can be interesting building blocks
for multi-agent learning algorithms and
because and they have this property of
being attracted to
uh this pure nash equilibria points yeah
um and this is a paper i can recommend
you if you want to um
understand better this uh
learning dynamics and where uh the link
with
evolutionary game theory
is being made not only for this learning
automata but also for other
um
reinforcement learning operating so
multi-agent reinforcement learning
algorithms we actually also used
these
insights in learning automata for
example to understand
better the convergence of ant colony
optimization algorithms so what we could
show is that and the update rule of how
these pheromones are going are being
updated and that they basically resemble
the update rules of learning automata
combined with a heuristic component
which is then typically used in in aqua
algorithms
now of course you can say yeah but if
you're uh learning automata can bring
you to a pure nash equilibrium point
maybe this is not always what you want
and that's of course
indeed
a good remark
so what you see again is our battle of
the sexes um
um our
game into the left-hand side
and if we then apply this learning
automata and the they will be attracted
to one of the pure uh nash equilibria
so um one agent will get a reward of two
in the simple example
and the other agent only a reward of one
uh so okay we can see yeah maybe this is
also not fair to the to the agents maybe
there's other solutions
uh and a fair solution for example would
be to converge to the mixed natural
equilibrium and we can also have
learning all
automata who can actually do this
but in uh quite some games the the mixed
natural equilibrium is actually worse
than uh one of the
either of the pure nash equilibrium
so this is why and we thought okay
maybe we can um build on top of this
convergence to this nash equilibria a
kind of periodical policy and this is
what you can see at the right bottom
where the agents actually
learn to alternate
playing between these
pure nash equilibria
and we then apply this to different um
let's say uh
examples motivating from real life
problems for example here
um how to deal with uh this um
parallel uh architecture and so here you
see what we call slaves and the idea was
that they had to learn and to request
and the right amount of
uh let's say work
and to this master node in order to
optimize uh the system so they were
really doing this with
independently learning to write to ask
the right amount of
work and they were
coordinating somehow
uh
indirectly
and there and as such optimizing uh the
system
um other uh settings we looked at
or for example um unlike this chemical
uh production plant and so the
reason why i showed this example is
because it's actually like a queueing
algorithm also
or a queuing problem
so these learning automata are also
quite robust to the fact that under
reward they get to update their
probabilities and comes with delay and
also comes in a very asynchronous uh
manner
and
we were also able to show and that the
resulting policy and such a periodical
policy
and was um
actually better um performing better
than
uh other approaches
and now you might wonder why we would
need and this this policy like
alternating between this pure nash
equilibria and so in which cases
um
your
pure alternating between the pure nash
libria is actually better than playing a
stochastic policy which would allow you
to play
uh the mixed nash equilibrium
and and we analyzed this this problem
further and um this becomes um better
than playing uh the mixed nash
equilibrium uh when the let's say the
size of the jobs is actually quite
big and so if you have very
many small jobs that naturally mingle
together
a mixed strategy will
be a good strategy but if you have
bigger chunks of
uh work that needs to be done
then it's better to have this periodical
policy
so to switch from one pure equilibrium
to another one
um
this is just to say that we also analyze
this learning automata in a markov games
and uh also in continuous action
settings because
i have been talking now about
settings which are discrete states but
also discrete actions
but actually you can also extend this
learning automata to
continuous action settings and what you
see there at the right hand side
is again a
kind of
reward in action scheme
where
the top line and the three boxes on on
the top you see how and they are getting
attracted to
again a pure
nash equilibrium
so the the drawing on on top is in the
actions versus actions also they
both independent agents and converge uh
two playing actions which are unlike in
an equilibrium point
and then of course
to explore
you have to like switch to another nash
equilibrium and so that becomes of
course more
complex in a continuous action setting
and because you have now to identify
a regent region around this actions or
or and the range of actions to which
this nash equilibria have uh converge
but you see and that is way of of
exploring
which is independent but somehow
coordinated
allows us and to to get a stable kind of
learning and we're on top of this we can
build other algorithms for example this
alternating uh between different uh nash
equilibrium
so
i think we seem to have somehow
forgotten and that real independent
learning
is actually possible and with this whole
deep
uh multi-agent reinforcement learning we
have today
so my main message is that maybe we
should go a bit um back uh and and look
at the history of of how algorithms were
uh designed uh in the past of course i'm
not arguing here and that we should say
to this tabular settings
but maybe we should find another way and
not um
just have this plain end-to-end learning
um but but try to
really um
look at how exploration
was done in the past and so this is
basically my my conclusion i still
believe that he's learning automata or
interesting building blocks for
multi-agent reinforcement learning just
because of their building exploration
strategy and that really allows us to do
this uh independent learner learning but
of course
it's it's a challenge on how to uh
combine them with a complex function
approximation
and also
how to combine them for example with
heuristic information or
things like advice and demonstration
because of course and these ones then
would interfere
with their uh building exploration so we
should uh of course not then
lose the fact that they are
so stable uh when we apply them in a
real distributed
setting
and this concludes my talk here
great thanks a lot uh let's see are
there any questions right now
uh okay oh
let me go over here
yeah
i think i missed some elements of the
model like
uh so when you say that the players are
learning the automata are they
observing what are they observing like
they're just observing their own uh
feedback
they just get their reward and based on
the reward
they're using their probabilities of
selecting actions they're not observing
any state information about the other
agents nor the actions
nor the rewards that the other agents
receive they're really
independent learners
they're taking making moves in the
automaton where they're giving the input
out some time i think that's the part
that i missed because i i know about
that's where each player is on automaton
and they play against each other but
that's not what you mean here right yeah
each agent actually is a learning
automaton it's using a learning automata
update scheme to update the probability
of its actions
so if you for example look at the markov
game
then
each agent within each state have a
learning automaton so each time the
agent arrives in a certain state it has
its learning automaton and it activates
learning automaton and it's using this
to decide which action to select
it gets a reward and it updates its uh
probabilities over these actions
okay thank you
thanks
um maybe i'll just ask one more question
and then we'll uh
go to the next talk in the interest of
time um i was just gonna say uh so i
guess you mentioned like uh challenges
in combining with like function
approximation at the very end i was
wondering if maybe you could just say a
little bit more about that
uh yeah we we did this actually but with
very simple uh
function approximator so basically like
a kind of interpolation scheme so very
simple where you can nicely control
everything of course not with with the
deep neural network so i think that if
you
want to apply it with with a deep
approximation network
then
we we have to uh think better about how
to update the probabilities of these
actions so not just doing one update
step as we typically do
uh a gradient step in in in the right
direction so to say um but we we should
focus on
um
the let's say the relative updates we do
implicitly for all the actions
so we should try to
keep the same
update as as with the learning automata
because it tells us
if when
action is being updated this way all the
other ones that were not selected have
to be decreased with or increased with a
certain amount and it's really
uh within that scheme and that that
allows us to do this independently and
being attracted to a nash equilibrium
cool that makes sense uh let's see are
there
any other questions before we move on
all right well why don't we give ann
another uh round of applause and thanks
again we're glad you could uh drop in
and join us
[Applause]
all right uh let's see uh should we